yet another day and yet another example
of a federal law violation by Donald
Trump targeting a specific company on
Twitter I'm starting to feel as though
the English language is being pushed to
its limits to adequately explain the
crisis level stuff that's going on right
now with this administration Trump is
now threatening Harley Davidson with
being quote taxed like never before if
they move overseas which they're being
pushed to do because of Donald Trump's
own tariffs so I want to break this down
step-by-step for you
Donald Trump started a trade war he put
tariffs on Chinese European Canadian
goods as predicted the countries that
were tariffed by Donald Trump decided
that they were going to put in place
retaliatory tariffs this is how trade
wars work completely unsurprising and as
a result we've had some American
companies harley-davidson being one
example announced that they're going to
move some element of their business
overseas in Harley Davidsons case they
are going to try to get around tariffs
that would increase the cost of each
motorcycle by 22 hundreds by moving
production of their European market
motorcycles out of the United States so
Harley moving that production overseas
is a direct response to the
repercussions of Donald Trump's trade
war when harley-davidson announced hey
this is what we're going to have to do
Donald Trump goes on Twitter and he
threatens Harley with punitive taxation
tweeting yesterday quote a
harley-davidson should never be built in
another country never their employees
and customers are already very angry at
them if they move watch it'll be the
beginning of the end they surrendered
they quit the hora will be gone and they
will be taxed like never before
understand what's happening here Trump
first hurts Harley Davidson by starting
a trade war Harley reacts to save their
revenue and Trump says I will hurt you
even more if you try to get out from
under the destructive effect
of the trade war that I started Trump
forced them to make a business decision
and now he's going to punish them for
making that business decision to try to
save their profits and of course it
won't matter to Trump supporters Trump
supporters will say you know it's
Obama's fault because he was weak on
trade or congressional Democrats
obstructed fixing trade deals so Trump
had to do this and Trump's just gonna
have to be tough in order to make this
right which of course makes no sense
since the whole point of fixing trade
was to be good for American businesses
not so terrible for American businesses
that they say wow we have to save
ourselves and offshore even more jobs
which is exactly what's going on I was
thinking about how the EU targeting
harley-davidson is actually kind of
clever because Harley is seen as this
kind of Heartland American icon and by
putting harley-davidson in a position to
have to make this decision Harley is in
a position where conservatives will have
to decide do we denounce Harley because
we're supposed to see Harley as this
American icon but at the same time if we
say we support what harley-davidson is
doing we're kind of criticizing Donald
Trump because we were admitting that
this is what they have to do because of
Trump's trade war and the real lesson is
that trade war a policy by Trump is half
haphazard and it's also a losers policy
Trump can't win it right we can go into
the esoteric economic details or we can
just understand that in broad strokes
Trump can't win the trade war businesses
are going to suffer middle class
Americans are going to suffer and I
don't take pleasure in this every time
we talk about this Pat people email in
and they say David you anti-american
freak you're pleased by what's going on
no first of all if if you say that you
must acknowledge that there are bad
things going on that's number one so why
don't you just criticize the policy as
opposed to criticizing me I don't take
pleasure in 400-point swings in the Dow
I don't take pleasure in the exploding
of oil prices that we're now seeing and
I certainly don't take pleasure in this
economic instability I
just not gonna sugarcoat it for you I've
got to tell you the truth I thought we
were supposed to be sick and tired of
all the winning at this point yeah I'm
presidency we're not really seeing that
we're not seeing it we're not seeing it
with Harley Davidson and I also want to
give you another example of Jack Daniels
whiskey that is really going to suffer
under Trump's trade war I'm really
thrilled to tell you that today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman as many of
you know I have been working very hard
on this program to reduce stigma around
mental health to reduce stigma around
seeking help and I have a family that is
very involved in mental health and if
you've not already heard about better
help it is a tremendous resource better
help gives you through your phone and
computer affordable private access to
licensed trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you they are LGBT friendly you can
even say I want a counselor who's not
religious if that's important to you if
your initial match isn't a good vibe you
can switch to a different counselor and
the beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over video phone
and text from at home and on the go it
is way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started
we've put a link in the description if
you're watching on YouTube once again
that is better help calm slash PA que ma
N